what's like your proudest moment cuz
there as a single mom and and you play
we're going to get to the movie um but
the series but um you play um she's a
single mom and the you're you've been a
single mom so like what's your proudest
moment because it's hard to be there for
everything to hold down a job to it's
super hard and you know when you're
young I was very young and I'm for
example now that I'm 51 I think we
talked about it a little bit when we
were the last time that I saw you it's
like you know I wish I had done things a
little bit you know different because I
didn't know I was young I was 20 years
old when Manola when I had Manola so I
was like kind of like raising myself at
the same time so what I mean I should
have been going to therapy or somebody
should have been guiding me uh but I am
so proud that he turned out amazing and
super
hardworking and that he you know that he
wants to do things in life and he's
excited about life I think that's what
all mothers you know wish for yeah and
just polite and respectful I'm like
that's my thing I'm like if anything you
can be any of the things but just kind
would be good kind yeah kind to to other
people and I mean I don't have anything
bad to say about my son um so I did a
great job I love it you got to be proud
of that so wait I want to show a couple
old photos of y'all together so the
first is this look oh look at you oh my
God I think that was in Miami some
Halloween or something well that's a
Full Circle you're talking about a
character in Miami in Miami yeah yeah I
remember I think that was around the
time one time like I was dropping him to
school and he turned around and said to
me mom don't forget that tomorrow it's
like the parents uh teacher thing yeah
and I'm like yeah sure I know he's like
and then he was going to close the door
and he turned around and said don't
forget to dress like a
mom I was like I was like I don't even
I'm like wait don't just say that I got
out of the car what does that even mean
my son says things to me about my
wardrobe he literally made me change for
my girls night out just going out to
dinner he was like oh so you're going to
wear that and I was like damn I was well
then you're worse than me because at
least I was in my 20s I was like 23 when
he told me that you're like I should be
killing it right now no wait that's me
they're Honest Kids I love it um there's
there's also this one though in his
favorite 101 Dalmation Speedo which is
so great like that's where are yall what
no that's Colombia I was at the beach
that's my cousin Joi and we're just like
at the you know the local beach in in
columia Manola there you know I love it
oh I haven't seen that easy to see them
small I know now he's big
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home